as you can imagine i work with a very
large staff that's what happens when you
get to my level in the business uh one
member of my staff has been emailing me
literally every day very excited telling
me he's got some big news to share
he says it's something that's gonna blow
me away uh i have not found out what
this is about yet do you know what this
is about sona i have no idea yeah well i
thought we'd have him on the podcast to
make his big announcement
and maybe we can share in his
celebration whatever it is i'm sure yeah
that sounds big please welcome uh team
coco software engineer
john dennick uh danic this is exciting
what's your big news all right i have
some earth shattering news coming from
the camp of team coco are you sitting
down
i am sitting down okay
yeah and i'm ready this is uh this is
cool
lay it on us man i've been psyched about
this for a while i am thrilled to
announce that we are changing our
marketing platform and now partnering
with mailchimp
wait that's your news we're partnering
with mailchimp you seem a little less
excited than i am
uh
i love uh the name mailchimp uh and i
i'm a big fan of the company too i
didn't think i honestly didn't think
that was your announcement i thought you
were going to tell us something like
you uh won the sweepstakes uh having a
child something like that oh i guess
those would be cool too but no this is
about mailchimp
okay all right
i'm guessing that you have more to say
about this mailchimp announcement oh you
know it all right there's a couple
reasons why i'm excited
primarily just the improvements and
features that come with moving to
mailchimp first of all you got
deliverability in the past
we'll say that some of our email going
out to users was marked as spam i don't
want to say how much but you can imagine
it was a decent amount yeah
you know i think it's unfair danic that
the rap on you is that you're a stilted
awkward speaker
because
this is one of the most natural
conversations i've ever had
anyway
uh danic i love efficiency but it seems
like now i'm paying you to do less work
is that the idea with this mailchimp
thing uh i mean you could say that in
more or less words um it doesn't feel
great as a software engineer to see your
work end up in spam folders i don't
think that's gonna be nearly as much of
an issue anymore wow huh the gospel of
conan will end up in more inboxes
that's exciting that you can reach more
people it won't go to spam you must be
really excited conan i am i'm i'm a big
star i'm an artist uh and like any
artist bihi michelangelo
or rodan he likes to see his work
displayed and preserved around the world
all right um but i mean is it is it a
helpful and efficient uh you know system
mailchimp is is that something that i
can depend on 24 7. oh yeah you can
absolutely depend on it it's definitely
efficient they have all these automation
setups you can configure triggers in
response to user events to send out
emails
so
less work on my end manually speaking
yeah yeah yeah okay less work for you
uh-huh i mean it's clear to me
danic that you have given this a lot of
thought
yeah well i've spent days working on
this yeah and even probably written down
some of your thoughts that's sort of the
impression perhaps perhaps they were
you know emailed to me earlier
[Music]
but a lot of them are coming from the
heart yeah i can tell i can tell you're
very passionate yeah but just correct me
if i'm wrong you love mailchimp because
it's easier to use right so am i paying
you to work less hard i mean shouldn't
you get less money now because you're
using mailchimp shouldn't i
reimburse you less because you're
putting in less effort thanks to the
wonderful mailchimp i think you should
think of it more as you're freeing me up
to lend a hand in other things that
we're working on around team coco oh
that's smart wow that was smart he's
very very good
this danic guy
you know we should talk more or
better yet a lot less
[Laughter]
well this is uh this is cool now how are
you using mailchimp don't tell me you're
using it to send out our first
newsletter is that what you're doing oh
you bet that we are yeah that should be
coming soon in the next few days i'm
very excited to uh get in and look at
the analytics after we send it out see
the open rates see the improvement over
the previous services we've used all
right you're getting me all hot and
bothered now with your analytics yeah i
know well uh danic i look forward to
seeing you at the christmas party
in uh 2026
but not until then um you are again
you're one of the uh you're a stunning
conversationalist
and uh and i'm i'm glad that you're so
excited about mailchimp and now i am too
yeah so much so that i'm gonna say this
try mailchimp today at mailchimp.com
conan
do it